now all of us are glued to our screens
watching just one thing at the moment
and that is a 2022 FIFA World Cup here
are five facts that you guys should most
definitely know the first ever World Cup
was held in 1930 and it was won by
Uruguay who defeated Argentina 4-2 in
the finals there are only eight teams
have ever won the World Cup and Brazil
has won it five times the most by any
team so far there are going to be 32
teams who are going to be competing in
this edition of the World Cup but from
2026 onwards there are going to be 48
teams who are going to be buying for the
same trophy the victors of the World Cup
did you know are going to be paid a
whopping 344 crore rupees and the
runners-up are gonna be making 245 crore
rupees massive sums indeed and guys for
the first time in the history of FIFA
women referees are going to be judging
matches and tremendous speed indeed now
guys I am supporting Brazil comment down
below and let me know which team is
supporting and for more facts like this
follow don't memorize And subscribe to
our Channel